so we're talking about starting small
starting part time making sure that you
take steps every day to move that
business forward it's going to be
extremely important you're much more
likely to keep with it if you know that
you're making a little bit of money and
it's more important to spend time every
day doing a business then to spend you
know a month full time on the business
and then quit because you're not making
enough money to support yourself so you
know you have to let time for mental to
build and that's going to come from
spending time every day to me that
visits for and again it should be
something that you are excited and
passionate about you should come home
wanting to do it if you're not excited
about it and you feel like it's work and
it's no boring especially at the
beginning like if you don't love it at
the beginning you're not going to love
it it's hard to grow into something like
that you got to really love it right
from the start as it goes on it may take
its toll on you but you gotta love it
especially at the beginning and if you
don't then go back to the exercise
number one figure out a different
business it's not that you may not be
the right fit for an entrepreneur you
just may not have the right idea then
you should want to come home and work on
your business alright moving on another
quick quote John Johnson have creator of
the ebony magazine's the secret of a big
success is starting small and dreaming
bigger and bigger dreams and this is
important a lot of entrepreneurs have a
huge vision for what they want to do and
that's great and it's good to map out a
lifestyle that you want if you want to
you know work 20 hours a week or live
from an island or whatever it is that
you want that's great but it's important
to realize that that big dream starts
with small steps and doing those small
steps every day so just because you're
doing something small it doesn't mean
that you're not doing something
important those small steps gather up
and if you take action every day they
become big important steps so start
small and keep dreaming bigger and
bigger dreams
next thing is a quick launch plan so if
you are just starting your business
quick pass is create something that
you're going to do every day and at
least 15 minutes I don't want to make it
you know too onerous and ideally you're
able to spend a couple hours on some of
these days right you won't get a lot
done if you only do in 15 minutes a day
but I want that to be a minimum but if
you can't spend 15 minutes a day
especially in your first month launching
your business it's going to be hard to
make that a success so what helps at
least I found is if you sit down and
plan out a list of things that you're
going to do every day so they want to do
this to this and then you check it off
as you get them done and just by having
those checks going it gives you a mentum
it feels like you're doing something and
and you have a little bit of power
behind you some steam that's building up
so it's important you don't want to make
it you want to miss a day really if you
do the first ten days and it's going
really well you don't want to miss that
day 11 you want to get that 11 thing in
and the 12th in the 13 thing so you'll
to task may vary depending on what
business you're in and we can get into
some of the specifics later or with the
questions but I think it's really
important to have something that you
create and you can either have it on
your desktop or print it off or put it
on the wall and Mark off what you're
going to do every day and slowly start
checking them off as you get them done
and that'll start boosting your plan and
especially if you you know had a really
hard day at work it comes home and you
can see what you've done and you know
you're working towards this bigger dream
and so I found that to be really helpful
to keep keep you on track and keep you
working every day
startup rule number four build around
the customer and this is another big
mistake that a lot of entrepreneurs make
they think that they have a great idea
and so they start working in isolation
of talking to the people who are going
to end up buying whatever product or
service that they have and the best way
to build a business is to start talking
to your customers before you actually
launch your company you want to talk to
the guys we're going to pay you right so
talk to the people find out what their
challenges are and build a solution
around those challenges and a quick
example from my first company and
something what not to do help you guys
can learn from that I had a biotech
software company I was 19 years old and
it was pretty complex tough are soft was
being used by NASA and Johnson Johnson's
being used to try to find cures for
cancer and of all the features that are
in that software the most complicated
one was the ability to do undo redo in
unlimited time so if you make a mistake
you can undo you can go back and in Word
or Excel you can go back I don't know
maybe plenty steps in our software you
can go back all the way to the beginning
and we thought this is so great people
going to love this feature it turns out
nobody cared and we spent all this time
developing this feature but nobody cared
about because we did it in isolation
without talking to our customers and so
you really want to make sure you're
talking to your potential clients before
you start building your product the
service now luckily for us we had enough
in our software that people still wanted
to buy was still helpful and valuable
for them so we were still a bit you know
build successful company but we could
have done a lot more if we didn't make
those mistakes early on so you guys are
a great opportunity now here if you're
just starting your business or thinking
about it before you start spending money
because anybody can spend money right
it's not hard to spend money they give
you a million dollars you can go spend a
million dollars in million different
ways I'm sure but not everybody can make
one and the making money comes from
helping your customers solve their
challenges so start talking to your
customers start talking to people who
are facing problems and offer a
potential solution to them I like
starting with a service if you can
product because there's very low cost to
start it up and it gets you really close
to the customer so as much as you can
and build around their specific problems
and pain points and they will guide you
and tell you what they want you just
listen to them and hopefully be able to
really explode your business so a couple
of quick quotes Ray Kroc is from
mcdonald's of you if you work just for
money you'll never make it but if you
love what you're doing and you always
put the customer first success will be
yours so this also ties to that first
point of a passion you know again if you
just doing it for the money you're never
going to make it when the Ray Kroc but
you exported to love what you're doing
and the second part there is always put
the customer first so you're learning
about your customer figuring out what
their problems are and building an
experience or a product service
specifically designed to help them solve
whatever challenges that they're facing
next one Mark Cuban owner of the Dallas
Mavericks now and successful
entrepreneur with broadcast calm it got
acquired by yahoo for billions of
dollars i just tried to learn the
technology better than anyone else and
find the best way to help my customers
so he was going in against big
competitors and this is an opportunity
for any entrepreneur you know what we
don't have in money and resources we
have an ability to be flexible interview
to service our customers if you look at
any big company the service usually
sucks right you call in and you're put
on hold and you can't get through to
somebody and they're really slow and the
approximate services are are delayed and
nobody really has a lot of good things
to say about most big companies and
that's where you as an entrepreneur have
an opportunity you can go up against
these big guys by better listening to
the customer and creating the solution
is exactly tailored to what they need
and then also providing awesome service
right if people can call up and talk to
a person or email and get a response
really quickly and know that somebody is
there listening to them and helping them
then they're more likely to buy more
tell their friends you know towel helps
potential partners spread the word and
that's your goal as an entrepreneur the
more you can get people to talk about
you it saves you a lot of time
on sales and marketing a lot of expenses
as well so as much as you can you know
your business and then try to build a
product or service it really Taylor's to
your customers and the problems at their
face